Let's go next to the caller.
Who is calling in from the, uh, two five,
four area code?
Who's calling today from two five four.
Hey, David, it's Matt.
Hey Matt.
What's up?
Oh, no.
Too much.
Two questions.
And they're pretty short.
Number one is, um, how do you do this every
day?
Uh, I, I take weekends totally off.
That's how
well my quote, the reason I ask is pay.
For example, yesterday what happened yesterday
in the news, we had two big things.
We had to just, we had the Supreme court saying
that Trump's taxes could be a without for
the time being.
And then you had before that the, um, court
say that, um, McGahn had to testify, right?
So you get, you get one good thing and then
minutes later you get hammered with something
that, you know, makes it seem like everything's
political and justice doesn't exist anymore.
And so I'm just wondering what your thoughts
are on that issue.
Well, I would actually say it's sadly worse
than you, then you're even pointing out, because
even the good thing that McGahn has to testify,
he has to testify.
But even if he does, he can assert executive
privilege to every question that's asked.
So it's like even how hidden in the good result
is the reality that we'll probably never get
anything substantive out of him.
And the theme is that power tends to win because
we have two justice systems in two financial
systems, et cetera.
So I wish I could even agree that it was one
good thing on one bad thing, and it was one
bad thing and one thinly veiled good thing,
which is actually pretty neutral or not, not
so good.
So it's actually sadly even worse than you're
suggesting.
Well, I agree with you on that, but at the
same time, you can't claim executive privilege
to cover up a crime.
So if McGahn has just has to flank to exactly
what he said, the molar and the Mueller report,
then I would say that that would be a good
day for the nation to see him again in front
of the dayas there.
It would, well, the only thing that is that
my belief is that he would be testifying only
under the umbrella of the Ukraine impeachment
hearings.
So I don't know that the Mueller stuff would
necessarily even be part of it, but that remains
to be seen.
And then my second question is, what are your
thoughts on this whole, um, um, G Gallagher
Navy seal?
I don't think Trump quite knows exactly what
he's doing in this area.
Um, with, with our military, I, it's, it's
a dangerous game he's playing and he's, he's
in, I'm inserting it and I understand he's
a commander chief.
Sure.
But he's got no real, I mean, he's, he's a
businessman.
I get that.
And he was a real estate business man, but
it was, it was a family owned business.
It wasn't a, a big corporation.
So when you have some, like the military,
I spent 10 years in the act of service.
I'm still in the reserves slash IRR deployed
five times four direct one Afghanistan.
But it's just one of those things where, where
um, he's, he's, he's dividing the, the one
thing that shouldn't be divided.
Like I was watching Gallagher on Fox, I'm
not sure when he went on, but he was saying
that it's all about ego in that, you know,
the people above him are just out to get him
and this, that and the other.
And he's saying that his buddies in the, in
the military support him and,
well, I mean, let me ask you, let me ask you
Matt, because my view has been that what Donald
Trump is doing by pardoning war criminals
is very dangerous because it could be seen
as a signal to people in active duty that
even if you do something which your superiors
aren't telling you is okay to do and which
the law says is an okay to do that, you're
being sort of signaled by the president.
That may be, it is sort of okay.
And that you might end up with a pardon.
That's my concern as someone, you're better
positioned to answer this than I am.
As someone who actually served, like you said,
five tours overseas.
Is that the way that this could be interpreted?
That maybe you can get away with more than
you're actually told you can get away with?
It's, it's a danger.
It's a dangerous, uh, thing to undertake.
I'll, I'll put it that way.
It's one of those things where, you know,
when you join the military, when you go overseas,
you receive all kinds of briefings from, you
know, the JAG officers, this and another about
the Geneva convention rules of engagement,
your Roe, your rules of engagement, all that
stuff.
And everything is laid out pretty much in
black and white.
So it's just one of those things where if,
you know, Gallagher went over there and he
did what he did.
I'm not saying they did anything significant.
He, you know, killed the bad guy.
But then he took a picture with the, you know,
in front of it.
Is that necessarily, you know, um, all that
bad?
No.
But it is against, you know, our rules.
So it's one of those things in our law.
So it's one of those things where if you did
the crime, guess what?
You know, you gotta you sign the contract,
you said okay.
To the, to the, to the laws that govern, uh,
you know, what you were doing over there.
Um, so I don't have any, you know, no, no
real sympathy.
He chose to do what he did.
Um, his, his brothers in arms, um, kind of
went against what he did.
And, um, I think he got what he deserved.
His life wasn't over.
Yeah, he wasn't, I mean, so I don't, I don't
know.
I don't know.
I'm, I'm, I'm just, I'm worried that, that,
that Trump is dividing the, the, the services
and the people who, you know, serve the country,
um, faithfully and who do it by the law.
Um, they see this and I'm worried that they're
going to look at this and be like, well, what
do we do now?
How are you going to, how are you going to
punish somebody in your ranks for going outside
of the bounds?
The, you got Trump in the white house saying,
well you know, this guy did it and he's cause
I mean I can't tell you cause I was in during
the surge and uh, you know, I enlisted in
2002 after nine 11 and I, I'm still in not
active, but um, and it's just one of those
things where I guess I'm just worried
I share that concern with you.
Matt, I should totally share the concern with
you and I really appreciate you, uh, calling
in and sharing your perspective.
I hope to hear from you again.
Thank you so much for the call.
Really appreciate it.